politics are stranger than fiction in
Argentina the story is hard to believe
is happening it really does feel like a
movie cover-ups spies finger-pointing
protests and a political and media
frenzy all linked to a terrorist attack
that happened more than 20 years ago in
January federal prosecutor alberto
nisman was found dead in his home in an
apparent suicide the suspicious part he
was going before Congress the very next
day to speak out against President
Cristina Fernandez de Kirchner nice man
had already submitted a report accusing
president Fernandez of covering up Iran
supposed role in the 1994 bombing of a
Jewish Community Center why would she
allegedly do that in exchange for oil
people have taken to the streets in
outrage against the government calling
nice man's death foul play but others
are saying hold on the evidence just
isn't there the president has pointed a
finger at Argentina's notorious spy
agency seated she thinks they're the
ones targeting her amino mama esta señor
Mac amino me van intimidad yo no les
tengo miedo did we mention its election
year in Argentina and the opposition is
having a field day as of now there are
way more questions and answers and the
mystery of nice man's death is another
chapter in the bigger mystery of who's
behind the 94 bombing the attack was on
the argentine israelite mutual
association or a mia it killed 85 people
and wounded hundreds more in the 21
years since not a single person has gone
to jail instead the investigation has
been stalled mishandled and tossed
around like a political hot potato the
case has been in Eastman's hands for
years WikiLeaks cables reveal he worked
very closely with the US Embassy and
Argentina spy agency and who did they
work closely with the CIA and Israel's
Mossad the cables indicate everyone
steered nice men toward Iran and away
from other possible suspects like agents
from Syria including people associated
with then president carlos menem who
specifically helped nice man in his
invest
gation hi miss do so argentina's spy
chief just for some context juice has
been around since the 70s that's when
Argentina's spy agency helped the
dictatorship track its own people part
of what's known as the dirty war in
which 30,000 Argentines were disappeared
in any case the president forced you sir
to resign in December but that didn't
and his relationship with nice Minh
hours before he died nice Minh called su
so multiple times and when Souza was
recently called to testify he was
nowhere to be found do you have your own
theory yet there are a million of them
was stew so mad about being removed so
he used nice Minh to get at the
president and even if no one actually
killed nice men could someone have
forced him to kill himself were nice
Minh and others mad at the president's
decision to pursue a diplomatic route
with Iran in the bombing investigation
and was nice mins report meant as
revenge or did the president and her
staff really play a direct role in his
death now a new prosecutor Gerardo Parra
Sita has picked up where nice man left
off and is pressing a judge to go
forward with the case against the
president however it shakes down and
whoever goes down in the process the
biggest losers maybe the Argentine
people and the family members of the
amia bombing victims themselves they're
left with neither straight answers nor
justice